bro I know all the numbers I did it like
you know how much time it would take you
to yeah yeah so a hundred thousands like
40 hours but the thing is the first like
ten thousand are easier the further you
get the bigger the numbers are and like
certain ones are less syllables see have
you ever talked about that anymore no
see that's interesting let's go on my
podcast tour they got some exclusive
yeah no I mean I feel like everyone goes
at you I feel like everyone goes at you
for the money but I think that's all I'm
good for I mean we know that but we oh
my girlfriend's calling yeah I'm
surprised you have one of those we'll
talk about that in a second you launched
that phone down hey Jesus Christ I'm on
my podcast store uh oh I just noticed
you got questions up there no they don't
oh they don't matter yeah
what's up with your girl what's up with
your girlfriend what's up with her yeah
what's good bro I stole that phone
earlier yeah there's some like drama you
want to talk about how often do you even
see your girlfriend well right now not
much because she's from South Africa so
we're working on getting her visa so she
can come here how did you meet her so
we're doing a video we're going to spend
50 hours in Antarctica me Logan Paul
Casey neistat we all flew to South
Africa we're gearing up we're about to
like board a plane to go over to
Antarctica we just get a call everyone
in Antarctica got coveted every single
one of them there's like a 10 person
crew they like do these Expeditions for
rich people whatever and the people that
came before us just gave them all covet
so they all had to be medevacked out so
the whole Camp was deserted right before
we were about to go so I just got [ __ ]
I just flew like 40 hours spent a couple
days in South Africa and we couldn't go
out so we were all super bummed I don't
really club or do anything but obviously
I'm with Logan and so he drags me out
and we we go out and I just met someone
and then I was hanging out with this
person it's a long story but I was
hanging out with this person at dinner
she was like hey do you mind if my
friend stops by for like two minutes I
was like sure and the second I saw Tia I
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like she's
hot as [ __ ] but I I but the thing is
like I don't get along well with people
that I don't like learning so anytime
like I meet people I have to like see
what their appetite is for like as if
not then I just get bored like very very
fast like my version of a date is like
reading books not like going out to
dinner so stuff like that like reading a
book next to someone yeah like we buy
two copies of the book and we read it
together or like the same book yeah or
we take IQ tests or some [ __ ] like that
like that's that's what I like doing no
but it is I find that girls love that
[ __ ] yeah not many
but they love taking IQ tests so that's
where I like I usually it usually get
it's hard for me because like not many
people are into the kind of things yeah
yeah so I usually like uh get that out
of the way first so I was like okay it's
very beautiful but like let's let's go
ahead and figure it out like is she into
this or not so I asked her what she did
and she's like oh I'm an author I was
like oh it's a great start she just
released a book and then I kind of like
went down my checklist of things like I
don't like being around people who don't
have like good emotional intelligence
and they gotta love to learn and when I
was single I had like this checklist of
like six things that like if I met a
girl that had these six things we'd be
like best friends and she like instantly
like checked all six of them and then
started dating so what was your first
date well then I left literally like the
next day back to America and so so I
really know how to yeah because I only
saw her at dinner with with her friend
for like a little bit so then I just
casually was like oh can you send me
your book and then I read her whole book
and you know just started talking to her
about it and then like a month later I
went back just to see her yeah it was
like a 40-hour flight like North
Carolina doesn't have a great airport so
I have to like fly to New York and it's
a layover you fly to Africa and then
just lay over then you fly to South
Africa it's brutal did she still live
there yeah well it's like a long
distance thing right now I'm just
imagining their second date was like she
wakes up and she sees like a chess 101
book and he's like study up yeah study
your best line because I'll see you at
seven just in a [ __ ] Park just yeah
it's so funny because like we like I
don't I've never met anyone who has like
a relationship like we do I don't know
I'm probably like the peak nerd yeah
it's so funny but I don't care I just
Embrace who I am but we literally that's
what we do we just watch documentaries
read books and we practice raising our
IQ and dumb things like that like the
thing is like I'm at the point now where
I I could make six figures in an hour if
I really wanted to like I could do a
tick tock brand deal or I could do this
or that it's like it's very hard to
justify spending that much time with
someone unless I'm getting better it's
just nice having a partner that by
spending time with them I become a
better version of myself and I don't
feel like I'm wasting time you know so
it's great very happy I feel that so is
she moving to whatever the government
lets her yeah we're working on it so we
got like a what is it like there's like
this 90 day Visa that we got we just
used up all 90 days like that so if she
tried to come back now there's like a 50
chance they're just like no go away I
kind of messed up we were just like yeah
this is great and then now here we are
with like three months left in the year
but we'll figure it out that's cool you
would think though with just on that
subject like like she makes good money
she would be a net positive for the
economy like why don't we want her here
I that's I've been going why like why
she's not going to take anyone's job she
she like makes tons of money on her own
like literally there's nothing but
benefits for her to be here and I'm
talking to an immigrant yeah and our
government's just like no [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that yeah go make money for Africa
not here yeah I know I took me [ __ ]
10 years and I just got my green card
yeah and I've been paying taxes here for
10 years when you were trying to get in
oh wait wait so you you lived here for
10 years without a green card yeah I
mean I've been on like eight different
visas that's crazy yeah that's what I'm
saying and wait really so when did you
get it the Green Card yeah in December
of last year yeah that's wild because
you've paid you know I could just based
on your views and stuff guesstimate
crazy amounts of [ __ ] taxes I mean no
but for again people out there think we
don't make much money he's paid an
absurd amount of taxes and then for him
to not even have a green card is so
unfathomable like you would think they'd
just be like he's creating jobs he's
paying taxes he's making this country
great or better sorry not great
very much
[Laughter]
you know you're nothing but net
positives and as a country we're just
like no [ __ ] you we don't want you thank
you man it's crazy no it's dumb positive
someone needs to fix it yeah it's it's
hey give me that red hat back just
kidding
oh my God
yeah maybe in like 20 years we'll see
run for press yeah I want to try to make
a ton of money and then just like give
it all away right before I announce my
campaign like I thought you're gonna say
buy the presidency
I imagine I have like 10 billion dollars
and then I just give it all away and I'm
just like I can't be bought I had it all
give it all away like that's pretty
powerful yep yeah yeah and then instead
like instead of like giving into
lobbyists or agendas I just like do
whatever's good for the American people
so I think it'd be a good idea yeah I
want it to happen because that would be
just the most insane story you could
actually very reasonably do it so many
people would know your face yeah I think
I could like to be on a time yeah I I
think when I'm 40 presidents are just
getting way too [ __ ] old like I think
like for two for younger presidents I'm
of them always being in their 70s yeah
so I think it would be fun to run when
I'm like 40 or something like that you
think you'd you think you'd beat Logan
because he talks about running you know
I said that on a different podcast they
said the exact same thing do you think
you'd be Logan oh man you podcast
they're all the same they they are
different different faces all right [ __ ]
yeah do you think if you ran now do you
think if you ran now there are hey
there's a podcast Illuminati they just
control all of them they're just puppets
yeah if you ran a couple years around
you think you could be Trump well you
gotta be 35 to run oh how old are you
24.
damn yeah so that's why I said I Gotta
Wait me too man yeah yeah you said our
age like
we're not a decade I'm 48 dude he's 53.
I'm 59. you're like what
29 31. are you really yeah wow
I take that as a compliment though yeah
yeah really wow
that was like a really bad that was a
nice really well